[Music]
tonight I'm Brian Ross investigates on a
week of remembrance for the 3,000 people
killed in the 9/11 terror attacks
Mary Jane booth an unanswered question
did the Kingdom of Saudi Arabia secretly
held the al-qaeda hijackers carry out
their plot will the u.s. finally reveal
the blacked-out names in this one secret
FBI report detailing how two of the
hijackers sneaked into California and
were assisted by people connected to the
Saudi consulate in Los Angeles very
significant mounting evidence powerful
evidence that the Saudis aided and
abetted that crime that killed thousands
of American plus the other victims of
9/11 the first responders still fighting
to get their due taking on Congress with
some powerful help your indifference
cost these men and women their most
valuable commodity time so one thing
they're running out of and our shout up
for the investigative reporter in
Mississippi
once again challenging the officials who
run the state's out-of-control prison
system basically even top prison
officials have admitted that the gangs
are in charge of these prisons from the
law and crime Network studios in New
York City's Herald Square this is Brian
Ross investigates
and good evening and welcome a sombre
week for America eighteen years since
the terror attacks that took the lives
of almost 3,000 people and after all
that time one very big question remains
unanswered in part because the FBI and
the US government may have kept the
answer secret did the Kingdom of Saudi
Arabia secretly help the al-qaeda
hijackers carry out their plot what does
the name of the mystery third man
blacked out in an FBI report the Justice
Department has just come out with this
decision that it will reveal the name
and nothing else we'll be joined shortly
by Andrew Maloney to talk about it there
were 19 al-qaeda hijackers that day of
terror in New York and Washington much
of it played out live on television you
saw a plane go in to the building among
the five on the jet flown into the
Pentagon American flight 77 were these
two Nawaf al-hazmi and Khalid Al Manar
both of whom the FBI discovered were
helped in coming to the United States by
two men from Saudi Arabia who were
closely tied to the Saudi consulate in
Los Angeles a once top secret FBI report
states that someone whose name is
redacted provided or directed others to
provide the hijackers with assistance in
daily activities including procuring
living quarters financial assistance and
assistance in obtaining flight lessons
and driver's licenses as part of the
lawsuit brought by the families of
victims the FBI and the Department of
Justice are now being asked to reveal
who's name was kept secret I'm asking
you for a commitment that the FBI will
release all of the documents that are
relevant to this litigation that you
will not invoke the state secrets Act
which has been raised as a possibility
and that you will provide full
transparency to those families were
simply seeking justice against Saudi
Arabia in the face of very
significant mounting evidence powerful
evidence that the Saudis aided and
abetted that crime that killed thousands
of Americans
well senator I'm not going to engage on
the specific litigation certainly here
in this setting I can assure you that we
will try to be as transparent as I think
we can responsibly be while at the same
time protecting national security the
FBI agent who led the Los Angeles
investigation Steve Moore now retired
filed this declaration in the lawsuit
directly tying Saudi Arabia to the
hijackers quote based on evidence we
gathered during the course of our
investigation I concluded that
diplomatic and intelligence personnel of
the Kingdom of Saudi Arabia knowingly
provided material support to the two
9/11 hijackers and facilitated the 9/11
plot my colleagues in our investigation
shared that conclusion unquote and that
to Saudi employees in Los Angeles quote
were active participants in that terror
cell associated with al Qaeda that
provided substantial financial and
logistical support to has me and al mid
heart in that document a third name is
blacked out lawyers for the families
have gone to court trying to get it and
today they got their answer I'm joined
here now by Andrew Maloney one of the
lead lawyers for the families of the
9/11 victims do you have that name I do
what is that name I am not at liberty to
disclose the name we have agreed to a
protective order that the FBI insisted
that we agree to so that we cannot
reveal information that they've given to
us not only the name that came out today
but for the last year they have given us
documents about a thousand pages of
documents some of them very very useful
for us but I can't share those with not
only you but even with my own clients so
they have continued to clamp down and
put the shroud of secrecy over
everything we do in the case I heard
director ray say he wanted to be
transparent or as transparent as
possible why then have this protective
order widened then can we not tell the
American public
clients what we've learned so far is
there anything you can tell us about the
name is it something that came as a
surprise to you no it was a name we were
familiar with all right a question for
you from our control room from executive
producer Rhonda Schwarz Rhonda what's
your question the Saudi government has
fought you for 18 years on this we
invited their lawyer to come on and he
declined to talk about the quote ongoing
case why are they fighting you so hard
what are the implications of this well
if we prove that the Saudi government
was behind the 9/11 attacks that is
essentially a declaration of war we
invaded two countries after September
11th attacks Saudi Arabia has been long
considered an important ally for the
United States but frankly they need us
more than we need them and they need to
come clean they need to cooperate you
need to comply with discovery that we've
demanded they've given us next to
nothing in the formal discovery process
that's ongoing in court there continue
to change their story about who was
doing what and what they were in terms
of their employees that were here in the
United States so nothing you've learned
today dissuade you from your theory
quite the opposite it continues to
corroborate and give us more rocket fuel
to to get this case to the finish line
there's one theory that the Saudis were
working with the CIA perhaps to launch a
undercover investigation try to
infiltrate al-qaeda and turn these two
al-qaeda members to cooperate I've heard
that rumor I don't see any evidence of
that it's a convenient thing for the
Saudi officials to say I think Prince
Bandar our former ambassador to the US
and Prince Turkey the former head of the
Saudi intelligence have said that they
knew who the hijackers were that they
knew the names and they knew that some
of them had come to the United States
they claimed that they told the CIA we
don't have evidence of that the CIA was
purportedly tracking to these guys while
they were in Malaysia but beyond that we
don't have any evidence that this that
the CIA our FBI was aware of what they
were up to the United States but it's
very telling that Saudi high-level
officials have said we knew who they
were and they had Saudi employees Saudi
government employees in Los Angeles and
San Diego
assisting these two future hijackers on
a daily basis to get them acclimated to
American society to provide a support
network and you can't have it both ways
if you're the Saudi government and you
say we knew they were and then later in
our litigation claim that the help they
were provided was innocent help and
there's no way you can prove that these
that the help they were getting from
Saudi officials was with knowledge and
intent and you got the name today at
what time
four o'clock from the Department of
Justice yes and now what's the next move
for you then well we are happy to have
gotten the name but there's a lot more
in the 2012 report that the name comes
from and a lot more beyond that that
we're seeking and we have long sought we
subpoena the FBI 18 months ago and as I
indicated they did give us some
information but they withheld a lot of
other information so taking the 2012
report alone that's the four-page
document you have there's all quite a
bit of additional material in that
report that it's been redacted we want
that and we were told today by the
Attorney General that he was exercising
his privilege of declaring it a state
secret and a matter of national security
18 years after the events that took
place he is claiming that we can't have
it because it jeopardizes national
security to me that's another way of
saying yes it's the Saudi government we
can't rock the boat and Rinaldi thank
you so much for joining us much more to
come on this story obviously you've led
the way in the information and you're
doing a great job coming up next the
other victims of 9/11 the first
responders who ran into danger inhaling
deadly toxins they're heartbreaking
fought to get their due when we come
back
next a little good news medical bills
and compensation for the 9-1-1 first
responders and survivors has now been
assured by washington nearly 25,000
claims where the victims fund had been
approved and some 14,000 more are
pending for those who breathed in the
deadly toxins in the aftermath of the
attacked captured so bravely in this
amazing footage by CBS photojournalist
mark laganja to me it sounded like a jet
flying over that's why i pianned up and
then you see the tower collapsing
what happened it collapsed the top
floors collapsed down there was no doubt
about what happened and why so many
became ill or died but it took some very
public shaming of members of Congress by
comedian Jon Stewart and the dying
victims themselves to get it done this
summer and it would be one thing if
their callous indifference and rank
hypocrisy were benign but it's not your
indifference cost these men and women
their most valuable commodity time
so one thing they're running out of
we're joined now by two very
knowledgeable guests on the subject
david ice brook one of the many lawyers
who represents the 9/11 victims and dr.
lee wilson who is the medical director
for the north well queen's World Trade
Center Health Program thank you both for
joining us dr. list let me start with
you what is it they're suffering from
this is cancer is in the lungs so thanks
so much for asking so if you think about
in the early days after 9/11 most of the
illnesses that were being seen were
directly related to the inhalation or
ingestion of the dust nasal passages
lungs ingestion so acid reflux and those
sorts of diseases you know over time
there was a concern that people were
exposed to many known improbable human
carcinogens most people are familiar
with asbestos but there are a number of
other probable human carcinogens in the
in the dust so we do cover conditions
like I was saying from the early day as
the sinuses both reflux and conditions
related to the lungs that we also cover
many cancers as well
David iceberg is there enough money to
cover all of these health issues this
goes to 2090 there is now this is an
uncapped fund Brian so the fight was to
reauthorize the bill and extend the
limits to cover any claims made through
2090 the World Trade Center Health
Organization that the doctor is involved
in had already been authorized extended
to two thousand ninety actually in the
prior bill claims could be made up until
two thousand ninety but the funds the
money the compensation for these people
was running out so that's why John
Stewart was the stalwart of the fight to
extend this and as a true bipartisan
vote one of the few bipartisan bills to
be voted through under this
administration may be absent some
criminal bills it was a ninety seven to
two vote to extend it and now it's an
uncapped fund so there will be money to
pay victims through two thousand ninety
the two Republicans have voted against
it Rand Paul of Kentucky and Mike Lee of
Utah said it's too much money there's no
limit on this well Rand one
what he called a paid-for
exception for all the money that was
paid into the fund for injuries he
wanted it to be allocated from a certain
area he wanted to be paid for by some
type of revenue stream from Congress the
other senator he had a problem with the
the years he wanted a capped and it was
a strong fight to against that and it is
an uncapped extension dr. Wilson is
there a way to treat these victims can
they be saved are they all doomed
I am absolutely there's treatment most
patients are getting conventional
treatments as appropriate for their
cancers thankfully we have funding from
the World Trade Center Health Program to
cover patients whose cancers meet the
latency and exposure criteria is set
forth by the government why is it
carry-out to 2019 so and this actually
is more applicable to what we call the
survivors so the folks that lived and
worked in the designated area because
there were children and younger folks
there my my cohort of my group of
responders most likely will not be
around till 2090 sorry guys what's their
their morale about all this they feel
they the government's finally recognized
the americas recognized what their
contribution was most most people
genuinely appreciate you know as they
they know that they either volunteered
or was sent down to Ground Zero on 9/11
to serve their country most of them
definitely appreciate that there is
funding to take care of them David when
your plan so is there an anger about
this there is an anger especially on the
clients where the spouses have passed
and they have now you know found out
after so many years especially when the
initial direction was it was safe to go
back in the area and as the doctor
mentioned before that you know the fumes
that they were inhaling were cancerous
and I just want to if we have 15 seconds
just it's important that people know
anyone doesn't have to be a first
responder anyone who lived or worked
below Canal Street for the eight months
following 9/11 was eligible for the fund
if you develop a cancer or respiratory
illness anytime from
now through 2090 so there's room for new
claims there that the fund was extended
purely for new claims that anybody even
children who live down there who develop
cancer when they're 50 when they're 60
they may have been five or ten years old
at the time are now eligible for
compensation up to 70 years from now
especially people who were exposed to
asbestos and the latency period there
could be 30 40 50 years for asbestos
they may not develop it till the year
2060 2070 they're eligible for
compensation there are new claims coming
in every day and dr. Wilson quickly
you're seeing them you're giving them
hope I do my best to get people hope I
try to focus on the positive when people
come in and all right like I always say
I like to see people when they're well
as well as when they're sick but we do
try our best to keep things positive
well doctor Lee Wilson and David iceberg
thank you so much for joining us very
hard and thank you for your very good
work both of you up next our shout out
for the veteran Mississippi
investigative reporter whose stories
have once again revealed chaos inside
the state's horrid prisons when we
return
and our shutout tonight is for a veteran
reporter who has now become his own boss
and his own editor Jerry Mitchell has
created the Mississippi Center for
Investigative Reporting and continues to
stir things up as you will see going
back following up on old stories to make
sure officials keep to their promises to
make things better with the cell phone
call from an inmate back in 2013 hey I'm
gonna tell you about all the corruption
that's going on inside of prison and all
these beatings and various things that
are happening and nothing's being done
about him it was a call to action for
investigative journalist Jerry Mitchell
six years ago leading to a damning
expose in the Clarion Ledger in Jackson
Mississippi and a series of supposedly
forms in the state prison system things
getting worse so once again Mitchell is
on the case now turning up evidence of
how the understaffed prisons are really
being run by criminal gangs in lockdown
we joined the Mississippi Center for
Investigative Reporting and ProPublica
to investigate critical understaffing
this video obtained by the Marshall
project shows what officials call a gang
ordered murder on an inmate seen running
from his attackers trying to get away
trapped in a shower cell stabbed 10
times and left for dead one of four gang
killings inside this prison alone it's a
horrible situation and basically even
top prison officials have admitted that
the gangs are in charge of these prisons
so we've uncovered all these things of
how gangs control how prisons operate
how did it come to be that the gangs not
the warden and the guards from the
prison well if you don't have enough
officers like at night because all you
have is a tower officer and really know
what they call floor walkers I mean we
expose in South Mississippi Correctional
Institution time after time this
happened so as a journalist this is a
real challenge because you can't be
inside there
you have to rely on them talking at you
and can you trust their accounts how do
you verify and double-check it I'll tell
you that's great well you you piece it
together you use inmates you use reports
you use incident reports and things like
that
use correctional officers who work there
really to kind of get a picture I love I
love reporting on hidden worlds and this
is like one of them it's become a big
issue in Mississippi this cell phone
video surfaced last week and once again
Mitchell's investigative reporting is
making waves in Mississippi part of the
prison on fire Vesta gay TV have
uncovered alarming staff shortages at
prisons across the country there is
simply not enough manpower in place to
keep tabs on the more than 3,000 inmates
that are housed there silence most of
this time you know they kind of do
circle wagons but prison officials have
acknowledged the problem when you don't
have the appropriate level of staff you
know safety is a concern before his new
series on prison expose Mitchell made
big news when he obtained this
photograph of three Mississippi college
students posing with guns in front of
the bullet-ridden sign commemorating the
death of Emmett Till a 14 year old
african-american who was lynched in 1955
after being accused of the rape of a
white woman I had a friend of mine say
this looks like a trophy shot so it's
you know 10.5 they're standing in front
of the Emmett Till song you know it's
just very sturdy the three students all
members of an Ole Miss fraternity were
suspended another black eye for
Mitchell's home state report you don't
you know you're your obligation is not
to protect somebody's reputation it's
ours to tell the truth so you're really
filling a huge gap in local
investigative journalism we really feel
we are on it's important thing
you feel I feel you know investigative
reporting is so key it's so important to
our democracy to to make it work right
we have to know about citizens have to
have knowledge what's really going on
indeed so our shout out tonight for
Jerry Mitchell on the Mississippi Center
for Investigative Reporting and all
those who have supported it including
our own executive producer Rhonda
Schwartz who serves on the center's
board that's our program for tonight
thanks so much for joining us we'll see
you back here next week